[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MICHAEL SIPSER: OK,
welcome everybody.
So we are here today,
lecture number 21.
Coming into the
homestretch of the course.
I'd say probably
this last quarter
of the course is a bit
more technical, perhaps.
So a little bit more abstract.
Some of the theorems are
going to be more difficult.
So I'll try to work through
them slowly and answer
your questions.
But you know, I
think you can expect
to find the material a
bit more challenging.
As we started-- as we started
with this theorem last time,
about nondeterministic log space
being closed under complement.
So NL equals coNL.
We kind of only got about
maybe a third of the way
through that.
So I'm going to
start over with that,
and spend kind of the
first half of the lecture
today talking about that.
And then we're going to
talk about the hierarchy
theorems, which are a
very important aspect
of the complexity landscape.
Basically, they tell you that if
you allow your favorite model,
let's say Turing machines,
to have more resources,
then they can do more things.
But we'll get to
that in due course.
OK, so let us go back to--
oops, reminder to myself--
go back to the
Immerman-Szelepcsényi theorem,
which is that NL
is equal to coNL.
So as I mentioned,
these are going
to be the same
slides as last time.
And I'll just try to
walk through them slowly.
I hope you get it.
But if you don't, ask
me or the TAs questions.
So we're going to first, I mean,
the thing we're going to show
is that the
complement of path is
solvable in
non-deterministic log space.
We already know that
path is solvable in NL.
That's easy to do.
You basically just
start at the start node,
and you guess the
sequence of nodes,
storing only the current node in
your log space working memory,
on your logs based work tape.
You guess the sequence of
nodes on the different branches
of the non-determinism.
And if you ever get
to the target node t,
then you can accept.
But how can a non-deterministic
log space machine
know or accept the
complement of path?
So it would have to accept
when there's no path.
And that is a lot harder.
But big surprise to the
complexity community
that it is true.
So as we discussed
last time, we're
going to talk about
computing functions
with a non-deterministic
machine.
And that turns out to
be a convenient way
of looking at this.
So we're going to have
non-deterministic machines that
have different branches of the
non-determinism on some input,
and it's supposed to
compute some function value
remaining on the tape.
But because of the
non-determinism,
you can imagine that
different branches might have
different function outputs.
Well, that's not allowed.
All branches must either report
the value of the function
that we're trying to
compute, or they can punt.
Basically, they can reject
and say, well, basically I
don't know.
So all branches must either
report the correct answer,
or they can say I don't know.
And some branch must--
at least one branch
must report an answer.
Must report the answer.
And that's what it
means to be computing
a function with a
non-deterministic machine.
And we're going to show
that certain functions can
be computed with
nondeterministic log space
machines.
In particular,
this path function,
which sort of incorporates
both the positive and negative
of both when there is a
path and when there is not
a path into the function,
because the function
has to answer yes when there is
a path from s to t and no when
there is no path from s to t.
So if you could do
this, you're done.
Because you can make
a non-deterministic--
you can make an NL machine.
So if you could compute
the path function,
you can make an NL
machine, which would accept
whenever the function says no.
And the other cases, and
if the machine that's
computing the function rejects,
then you'll reject as well.
But you accept if
the function says no.
And so therefore,
you're going to be
making an NL machine which
does the complement of the path
problem.
So if you can compute the path
function, that would be great.
So that's what we would
like to be able to do.
So as I mentioned, we're going
to have two other values that
are going to be relevant
to computing the path
function, which is what
we're ultimately going to do.
And that's going to
be the number of nodes
that you can reach
from the start,
from the start node in
your graph, and the--
for-- R is the
collection of nodes and c
is the number of
reachable nodes.
So shown on this picture.
And here, if it's helpful to
you to see it in a more formal
[INAUDIBLE] is
you can think of R
as a function of the graph
and the start node, of course.
But sometimes we'll
just call it R,
when it's clear which graph and
start node we're talking about.
R is the set of reachable nodes.
So it's the collection u
such that the answer is yes.
And c is the size of R. So
the way we're going to start
is kind of an easy theorem,
though this is still
going to be relevant
kind of at the end.
But for now, it's really more
a practice with the concept
that we have come up, you
know, this function concept
that we've just introduced.
So I want to say that the path
function, with an NL machine.
Then I can compute the
count with an NL machine.
So understand what a computing
the path function means.
That you have your NL
machine, and every branch
has to either say I don't
know, which is reject.
Or it has to have
the answer, which
it's going to be yes if
there is a path, and no
if there is no path.
And if I can be able to count
the number of nodes that do
have a path.
The number of nodes for
which the answer is yes.
And this, I think if
you're comfortable
with the definition, this
is more or less obvious,
because what you
would do is you would
go through the nodes
of G, one by one,
and test using your path
function what the answer is.
Yes or a no.
And every time it's a yes,
you add 1 to the count.
Until you've gone
through all of the nodes.
And then you have your
answer, which is [INAUDIBLE]
and that's c.
Now, if the machine
that's trying
to compute the path function
on the non-determinism rejects,
that's OK.
For computing c, that
branch will reject also.
But when you're-- some branch
has to get the right answer
on--
has to get the right answer.
And so then, you get the--
you know what's
happening with that node.
And so you then can either
increment the count,
or you move on to the next node.
I think I'm trying to say--
I'm not sure if I'm
making it any clearer
by kind of repeating myself.
But OK, here.
So you're going to start
out with-- you're given
the graph and the start node.
We're trying to compute this
value c, which is the number
reachable from the start node.
You start out with-- you
have a counter, which you're
going to set initially to 0.
And you go through
every node of the graph.
And if the path
function computation
says yes, you can reach u,
then you add 1 to the count.
It says no, you cannot reach
u, then you just continue.
And maybe I should
add another line here.
If the thing that's computing
rejects, then you also reject.
And then at the
end, you output--
so what we're going to prove
is the other direction.
If I give you the count, then
I can answer the question
for each node whether
it's reachable or not.
And this is the thing.
Because what it's saying that
is I can give you the count,
I'm done.
If we can get that count,
that's going to be enough.
So maybe even before
the check, and maybe we
should just answer
any questions.
Because if you're stuck
here, then you're doomed.
So I think it makes sense
to try to understand
what's going on at this--
because I think the
real guts of this proof
is coming on the next slide.
Kind of the main idea.
So I'm happy to take, if there's
any questions about this.
I'll just wait for
a second and see
if you're typing away there.
Well, why don't we
go to the check in.
Maybe that'll help.
Not a very difficult check in.
It'll come up.
OK.
Just a little practice
with the concept.
So I'm going to
give you some graph.
It has 9 nodes.
And I want to know the
value of the count.
So we'll assume that
s, the start node here,
is reachable from itself.
And now what's the value of c?
Are we good?
I'm going to shut this down,
give you another two seconds.
Please get your answer in.
OK, ready, set, end.
Yeah, the right answer is,
in fact, E, which is 6.
There is 6 reachable
nodes in this graph.
And that's what the value
C is supposed to tell you,
is how many nodes
can I get to from s.
And what I'm saying is that
if I can calculate that
in this sort of
non-deterministic function
sense, so if some branches
can get that answer,
then I can use that to test
for each node, whether it's
reachable or not, which is kind
of a little bit of a miracle.
That's kind of surprising.
Just knowing how many nodes are
reachable will allow me to test
whether each individual node
is reachable, because that's--
no obvious reason
why that would be.
So there's going to be a
procedure for doing that,
which is on the next slide.
And here it is.
So this is the key idea that
we're going to repeat later.
But so it's good to understand.
This is the slide you
really need to understand.
So I'm giving the graph.
Let's assume the
graph has m nodes.
Now, as I said.
OK, so let's just say,
what are we doing here?
Given that count,
we can compute path.
So we'll get the answer for
every node in the graph,
if I just know how many--
so I'll know, I
can get the answer
for whether a node is reachable
or not if I just have--
if I just know how many
reachable nodes there are.
So what I'm going to do is
get that count of how many
are reachable.
Now, I'm going to go to--
I'm going-- so look.
Let's see, what's the
idea here, before we even
jump into the algorithm.
The idea is let's say I know
how many nodes are reachable,
like 100 nodes are reachable.
Now, what I'm going to
do, what the algorithm
that is going to do is find
all 100 reachable nodes.
[? Go ?] 1 by 1, but
it doesn't matter.
Sort of conceptually, it's going
to find all reachable nodes.
And non-deterministically
guessing them.
So it's not sure in advance
which ones they are.
But it's going to
guess basically 100--
it's going to guess some of
the nodes as being reachable,
confirm that the ones that
it guesses are reachable
are reachable, and
then check to see
that that number equals 100.
On some branch of
the non-determinism,
you will guess right,
and you'll end up
with exactly the right set
of 100 reachable nodes.
And then you'll see, is t
one of those reachable ones?
In which case you say yes.
Or is t not one of
those 100 nodes.
And then you know
the answer is no.
Because if you've
guessed 100 nodes,
and you know they're
all reachable,
and you know there are
exactly 100 reachable nodes,
then every other node
is not reachable.
So that's the spirit of this.
And that's, I'm just
going to write that
down here in the algorithm.
Can you guys hear me still?
Yeah, somebody said my
audio is like flipping out.
I am getting a sign or
two of unstable internet.
So if you need me to repeat
anything, just send me a note.
Good, thank you.
All right, so well, maybe
I should speak slowly,
if it's not coming
through too well.
So what we're going to do
is go through all the nodes
of the graph, one
by one, and guess
whether it's a reachable
node or not a reachable node.
If we guess it is
reachable, I'm going
to also guess the path, which
shows that it's reachable.
And then I'm going
to-- and I'm going
to keep a count of how many
reachable nodes I found.
If that count agrees with the
value c I started with, then
I know I found them all.
And if t is not one of them,
then I know t is not reachable.
That's the idea.
So here's my--
this is going to be
a count of the number
of nodes that I
have found which are reachable.
That's k.
Now here I'm going to
non-deterministically choose,
is it a reachable node or not.
I've just called it two
branches of the algorithm, the p
branch or the n branch.
p means there's a path,
an n means there's no path.
So if I guessed p at this
point for this node u--
so I'm going to each of
the nodes one by one.
u is the current node.
If I've guessed that it
does have a path from s,
then I'm going to
guess that path,
to make sure that it
really is a reachable node.
If I fail to find
a path, then this
is one of the branches of
the non-determinism that
is going to fail.
It's going to punt.
It's going to say, I don't
know under this branch.
Because either
you guessed wrong,
and this node was not reachable.
Or if it was
reachable, you failed
to find a path, which shows
you that it's reachable.
There was some path, but you
didn't guess the right one.
Either way, you
made a bad choice.
You're just going to punt.
Now, if you have
determined that t
is that node that
you've just shown
is reachable, because at
this stage, you did not fail,
so you succeeded in
showing a path to u, then--
and u equals t,
then t is reachable,
so there is a path from s
to t, and you're finished.
Because you know, you've got
the answer you're looking for.
And so now you can say yes.
Otherwise, if u is
some other node,
then you can just
increase your count
of the number of reachable
nodes that you found.
So you found a reachable node.
If it's t, you're
great, you're done.
If it's not, you just
include that in your count
of reachable nodes.
Now, if you've guessed that
the node is not reachable, OK,
then you just proceed--
you're not going
to-- you're just
going to move on
to the next node,
because you're looking for a
collection of reachable nodes.
Getting some questions here.
But let me wait
till the end here.
Now, after I finish going
through all of the nodes,
so I'm finished
with this loop here
of going through
all the nodes, now I
see, did I find c
reachable nodes,
because k is the
count of the nodes
that I've found to be reachable.
If that agrees with c, then
I know I found them all.
If a differs from c, then
something has gone wrong.
Because I am told there
are c reachable nodes,
and I did not find
c reachable nodes.
So I made some bad
guesses along the way.
I guessed some node which
really is reachable,
I guess it was not reachable.
So I didn't find them all.
I'm going to punt.
But if I found them all, and
I didn't end up accepting it,
I didn't say yes at
this stage, so t was not
one of the ones I
found unreachable,
then I'm convinced
that t is not one
of those that are reachable.
That was not one
of those c nodes
that I found which
are reachable.
And now, I can say no.
So let me take questions here,
because I think we're, yeah,
that's the end of this slide.
This is kind of an important
piece to understand.
We can spend a couple of minutes
trying to work through this.
So somebody is asking, how
does nondeterministically
pick a path fail?
If you fail, what I mean
is pick a path from s to u.
So you have to go from s to
whatever your current node
u is.
So you're going to
pick some path to u.
You guessed u is reachable.
Now you have to demonstrate
it's reachable by picking
a path from s to u.
If you don't end up
at u, and the pair--
you don't want to go
forever on any branch.
So you're going to
limit it to m steps.
Your path has to be
of length m at most.
So after m steps, if you have
not reached u by that point,
you've picked a bad path,
and you're going to reject.
So what's the difference
between no and reject?
That's a good question.
Reject, in this case,
is an I don't know.
The algorithm could not
make a determination based
on the guesses that it's made.
In this non-deterministic
branch of the algorithm,
it made bad choices,
which doesn't
allow it to reach a conclusion
one way or the other.
Remember, this algorithm here
is computing a function now.
It's not an alg--
it can [INAUDIBLE]
nondeterministic algorithm in
the language recognition sense,
this is a function computer.
And so it has to get the answer
to the path function, which
is a yes or a no, or an I
don't know on some branches.
On some branches it's
allowed to do that too.
So no and reject are
totally different.
This is the same thing we
talked about last time.
Why do we need two
branches for p and n,
if we're only going to
have a proposal just
to have the p branch?
Well, but some nodes
are not reachable.
If you're going to look for--
if you have an unreachable
node, so it's not in R,
you can't get to
that node from s,
you have to skip over
that node, because you're
trying to find a subset
of the reachable nodes.
So you're trying to pick that
subset here one node at a time.
So if you're only
going to allow things--
you're going to require
everything in the subset,
there are going to be some
nodes which are not reachable,
and you're not going to find
a path because they're not
reachable, and you're
going to end up rejecting
all the time on that node.
So you're going to be--
the algorithm will not work.
So I'm not sure I understand
this question here,
but somebody says,
if t is reachable,
we output yes on that branch.
But don't we also output
no on some other branch?
That's a good-- let's
see what happens
if t is actually reachable.
How can we-- so
if t is reachable,
there's some branch that's
going to output yes.
We all agree with that.
Or at least, if you're
following, we agree.
But could some other
branch output no?
If t actually is reachable.
OK, that's a great question.
And no, that's not
going to happen.
If t is actually reachable,
how could a branch output no?
That must mean that
it does not guess t
as one of the reachable nodes.
Because it's going through
all of the nodes here,
you know, it's going
through all the nodes,
and picking them as
reachable or not.
If it picked t as one
of the reasonable ones,
then it's going to output yes.
Because it will
find, it'll either
output yes, or if it
doesn't find the right--
doesn't guess the
right path, it'll
end up rejecting on that path.
But some path will end up saying
yes, so if t is reachable.
And if you guess--
if you know t is reachable,
and you guess t--
you guess u is reachable at
the point when u equals t,
you will end up outputting yes.
The only way you
could not output yes
is if you guessed that
node is unreachable.
But then your count is
not going to add up right.
Because you wouldn't-- you
did not find all the reachable
nodes.
If t is one of the
reachable nodes,
and you know there are
100 reachable nodes,
and you skipped over
t as one of the ones
that you say is
unreachable, you at best
can only find 99
reachable nodes.
And you're not going
to end up saying no.
You're going to
end up rejecting.
So it's a very good question.
But you have to think through
what's going to happen here.
This c here is kind of a check.
It's almost like, well,
it's like a checksum,
if you know what it is.
It makes sure that
everything that--
if you got to c.
If you got to--
if k equals c at
this point, that
means you actually found
all of the reachable nodes.
So c is kind of a check that you
found all the reachable nodes.
Right?
So if k equals c
at this point, you
have found every reachable node.
And t was one of the
ones that are reachable.
You found t.
OK, let's see.
Is the reason we do this
with c essentially so
that we know when we
can stop guessing,
and correctly identify if
it's impossible to reach t?
Well, it's not a matter of--
it's not a matter of
stopping guessing.
It's a check that
we found everything.
Because we're going to go
through and do all the guessing
for every node no matter what.
So we're not going to
stop anything early,
unless we find that
t is reachable.
Then we can stop early.
But to show that t
is not reachable,
we have to go through
the whole process.
How come we intuitively
see that we don't
have contradictory branches?
That's sort of-- I was
trying to say that just now.
I hope that got through.
You can't have
contradictory branches,
because if you got
to this stage here,
you have found all
the reachable nodes.
So at this stage,
if you got to six,
you have made all
correct guesses.
You have found all
the reachable nodes.
You have convinced
yourself that they're all
reachable by guessing
the path to them.
And you've checked that
you have the right number
of reachable nodes,
because it equals c.
So you must have found them all.
So you cannot have a
contradictory answer,
because either t is one of the
ones you found, in which case,
you would have already said yes.
Or otherwise, you found them
all, and t was not one of them.
And so you're going to say
no, you can't have both things
cannot happen.
Let's move on.
So next thing we're going
to do is the next slide
is exactly the
same as this slide.
Except instead of
saying is t reachable,
I want to know is it reachable
within d, within distance d.
OK?
So--
Which is going to mean
exactly the same procedure.
Can I get-- instead of asking
can I get from s to t with
a path of any
length-- of course,
it's going to be
at most length m--
now I want to know, can
I get to from s to t
by a path at most length d.
These are the number of
edges in the path, say.
And that's the same procedure,
because instead of--
I'm just going to
cut things off at d.
But if I know in
advance how many nodes
are reachable
within d, I'm going
to find all the nodes that are
reachable within d and see,
was t one of the ones
reachable within d.
It's the same exact idea.
So here is the next slide,
which kind of shows that.
So here is the definition.
Path sub d means reachable by
a path of length of most d.
So R sub d is all
of the ones that
are reachable by a
path of that length.
And c simply is the count.
It's the number that
are reachable within d.
So if you understood
the last slide,
hopefully this slide will
seem kind of obvious to you.
I'm going to just
highlight all the changes.
So if I can now
calculate c sub d,
which is the number reachable
by a path of most of length d,
then I can test
whether or not nodes
are reachable by a
path of that length.
First, I calculate c sub d.
I go, I pick every node as
being reachable within d or not.
Now I just have to check that
my path that I'm guessing
has length at most d,
instead of length of most m,
which is what I had before.
Keep a count of the
ones that I found.
If that count equals c sub d,
then I know I found them all.
If it's not equal to
c sub d, then I've
made some bad choice
along the way,
and I can just punt
and say I don't know.
And if t was not one
of the ones that I've
shown to be reachable
within d, then I
know it's not
reachable within d.
And so I can say no.
So I don't know if this merits
any additional questions.
But this is really the same.
It's just a repeat of
the previous slide.
What's kind of amazing
is now the last slide
is going to be again a repeat.
Let me just foreshadow
where we're going.
But feel free to ask a question,
on this, or on the first slide,
if you didn't-- on the previous
slide, if you didn't get that.
Also, we can try to
help you out with that.
The next slide,
what I'm going to do
is show how to compute
all these c values.
And I should
mention, the value c,
which is the total
number of reachable,
it's going to be
the same as c sub m.
Reachable with an m, the
number of nodes of the graph.
So if I can get up
to c sub m I'm done.
And what I'm going to show
you is that knowing c sub i,
I can compute c sub i plus 1.
Or c sub d, I can
compute c sub d plus 1.
Since I'm using d as my
index here basically.
So c sub 0 we know is just s.
Well, it's just 1, because
you can just start with s.
That's the only thing
reachable within 0.
And then, once I know that,
I can figure out c sub 1,
c sub 2, c sub 3, and so on,
and then I get the c sub n,
and then I have the count of
the total number reachable,
and then I can test
the path function.
So the trick now is
being able to count.
Given c sub d, I would
like to figure out
what is c sub d plus 1.
Now, how am I going to do that?
What I'm going to do
is that's my goal.
What I'm going to do is
something in between.
I'm going to do a theorem
just like this, but instead
of giving c sub d, instead
of computing paths of d,
I'm going to compute
paths of d plus 1.
So knowing how many
are reachable from d,
I'm going to give a
test for whether things
are reachable within d plus 1.
And the fact is, that's easy,
because this thing already
tells me how to compute
whether I'm reachable within d.
And being able to be
reachable from within d
plus 1 means I have an
edge from something that's
reachable within d.
So if I can figure out which
are reachable within d, well,
and I just want
to see, do I have
an edge, do I have
an edge from one
of the nodes that are
reachable within d.
Then I'm reachable
within d plus 1.
Then if I can test whether
individual nodes are
reachable within d plus 1,
I can count how many nodes
are reachable within d plus 1.
That was that very first
easy theorem that I showed.
So I know there's
a lot of pieces
here that you have
to put together.
But in the end, each individual
piece is not that bad.
I don't know how many
of you follow me.
Oh no, this is not
supposed to be here.
There we go.
So here is the last part,
which again, is just
a simple modification of
what the previous slide had.
So I'm going to
show how to compute
the path d plus 1 function.
So testing if there's
a path of length d
plus 1 from s to some node t.
But only knowing how many
nodes are reachable within d.
So I'm going to
find all nodes that
are reachable within d, just
like I did before, but see
if any one of those
nodes has an edge to t.
Not necessarily that
one is equal to t.
Because that says that
t is reachable within d.
But I want to know, does
it have an edge to t.
That means t is reachable
within d plus 1.
So if I find all the nodes that
are reachable within d, and t
turns out to be reachable
from one of those by an edge,
then t is reachable
within d plus 1.
And if d is not reachable
from any of those nodes
with an edge, then t is not
reachable from d plus 1.
I hope you're following me.
I'm not sure you are.
So anyway, that's
the algorithm here.
And the corollary
is that you can
compute c sub d plus 1 from
c d, because if you can count
the past, if you can
test for each node
if it's reachable, as I
mentioned before, you go
through all the nodes, see
whether the reachable d plus 1,
and then count them up.
Now I have c sub d plus 1.
And now I'm done.
Because I'm going to compute
each d plus 1 from the value
d that I previously computed.
I'm going to do
that for all these.
Should say 0 here, actually.
And except, if the path says--
if the path function now
says that the answer is no.
Because I'm trying to do
the complement of the path
language.
And reject if the path
thing for m says yes.
And that's my non-deterministic
algorithm for the path
complement problem.
Anyway, maybe you need to
look at a little bit offline.
It's presented in a little
bit different way in the book.
I don't know if that will be
more or less clear to you.
But I think this has been
a little bit more unpacked
for the purposes of the lecture.
So let's just see.
I'm not getting any questions,
which probably means
I've lost a huge chunk of you.
But the good news is
we're going to move on
to a different topic.
But feel free to ask a question
on this if you want, or we're
going to shift gears now to
talking about the hierarchy
theorems, which is going to be
the second half of the lecture.
Also, not so easy,
I have to say.
Probably a little less
technical than this
one is, but it's
also there's going
to be spending time on just
mainly just one theorem.
But anyway, so looking
ahead to where we're going,
and then we'll have a break.
What we've shown so far,
these are the major complexity
classes.
I'm not including, let's say,
the complementary classes,
the co-NP type classes.
These are the major
classes we've seen so far.
And as we've seen, they form
a hierarchy of containments.
Some of those
containments trivial,
and some slightly less trivial.
But we have not shown
whether any of these classes
are different.
We've pointed out that there
were some unsolved problems
here, but do we know
any of these classes
differ from each other?
Or could it all
collapse down to L?
And the answer to that is
we do know that PSPACE and L
are actually different.
That we can prove.
And it relies on
the theorem that
says if you give a Turing
machine more space,
then you can do more things.
So because PSPACE is a
bigger bound than log space,
we know we can do more things.
In fact, because NL is contained
within log squared space
deterministically and
PSPACE is bigger than that,
we actually can
separate PSPACE and NL.
So we're going to
prove that today.
So basically, the
idea of the theorem
says that if you
give a Turing machine
a bit more time or a bit more
space, then it can do more.
So there are some
conditions on that
we have to-- we'll get into.
One of the conclusions
that we'll show
is that time n squared,
if you compare with time--
the things you can
do in n squared
time versus the things you
can do in n cubed time,
there are more things you
can do n cubed time than what
you can do in n squared time.
I mean, that's what
you would expect.
But it's not the
case that everything
we expect in complexity
theory, we can prove.
This is one of the
things we can prove.
So as you add more time,
you can do more things.
So this is a proper subset here.
So there are some
things n time n
cubed that are not n time n
squared, and ditto for space.
So that's going to be--
that brings us to
our coffee break.
And so feel free to
shoot me any questions
about what we've done so
far, or anything else.
And otherwise, we
will launch our timer,
and I'll see you
in five minutes.
OK, so getting some
good questions here.
Could we also make a solution--
this is getting back to that,
the logs-- the NL equals coNL.
Somebody's saying could we just
make another selection just
by non-deterministically
choosing C vertices,
and then checking that
they're all reachable.
That's effectively what
we're doing, but be careful,
because we cannot
store C vertices.
So that's why we're
doing them one at a time.
We can't guess all
C vertices up front,
because where are you
going to store all that?
We only have log space.
OK, another--
somebody is asking,
how much working space
do we need for storing
the intermediate steps?
I'm not sure what
intermediate steps you mean.
But if it's all to Ci values.
You know, C going from
C0 to C1 to C2 to C3,
we don't store those.
All you need, you need C sub
D to calculate C sub D plus 1.
And then you forget
C sub D. You couldn't
store all the C values.
But you don't need them all.
You only need the most recent
one to go to the next one.
OK, somebody's
asking, can I go over
why the complement of path
in NL implies NL equal coNL?
Because the
complement of path is,
essentially it's coNL complete.
I mean, it is.
So everything in NL
is reducible to path.
Everything in coNL is reducible
to the complement of path
by the same reduction.
And so if you can do
the complement of path
in any class, you can do all of
the complements of NL languages
in any class.
And so you can do the
complement of path in NL,
you can do all of the
coNL problems in NL.
And so then NL equals coNL.
You have to think
through the logic of it.
That part is not hard.
Why?
It's enough to solve the path
complement problem in NL.
That does everything else.
Because it goes through
the same completeness
phenomenon that
we've been seeing.
Somebody is asking about
the two set problem
that we talked about last time.
And is it, and you know, I
pointed out that that's in NL.
The two set problem.
Well, the complement
of the two set,
problem, the unsatisfiable
two set formulas.
That's in NL language,
because you can basically
look for a contradiction
non-deterministically in log
space.
I think I probably won't be able
to explain that in a minute.
But maybe we'll have our
recitation instructors
cover that in recitation.
It's a nice proof.
Not very hard.
But it's a nice proof.
It's something you have to
do, you have to think about,
you have to argue.
But it's still,
it's not super hard.
Understanding the
two set problem.
And the complement of two
set we showed, is in NL.
And because NL equals coNL,
also the two set problem itself,
without complemenation is in NL.
And in fact, is NL complete.
I think we're going
to have to move on.
I'll stick around
after lecture, in case
there's any questions that I can
answer quickly at that point.
Sorry if I couldn't get
to your question just now.
All right.
Continuing on here.
Shifting gears, the
space hierarchy theorem.
So as I mentioned,
I think, maybe
it's good to just go
back to this slide here.
We're going to do the time and
space hierarchy theorems, which
show that if you can
do a little bit more--
if you give a little bit more
time or a little bit more
space, you can do more things.
We're going to do the space case
first, because that actually
tends to be slightly, for
certain technical reasons
slightly easier.
So space hierarchy theorem.
So here is the statement
of the theorem.
So for any bound, think of s is
going to be some space bound.
And again, f has to satisfy some
technical condition in yellow.
Remember that it's
yellow because that's
going to be relevant later.
So there's going to be
some technical condition.
No matter what function you
have, whatever space bound
you have, as long
as it satisfies
this condition, which is a mild
condition, but you need it.
Whatever space
bound you have, you
can find a language
A which requires
exactly that much space.
So if f is like n
cubed, we're going
to find a language A that
requires n cubed space.
If it's n to the hundredth,
we can find a language that
requires n to the
hundredth space,
and cannot be done
with n to 99-th space.
Whatever it is, you can find
a language that requires
exactly that much space.
And if you like it a
little bit more formally,
so that means that it can be
decided in that much space,
but it cannot be
decided in less space.
Framing it at a
slightly different way
in terms of our
space classes, I'm
going to define a
notion which is kind--
it's not said this
way in the book,
but maybe it's a helpful
way to write it down.
It's space little o of f of n.
So those are all
the things that you
can do by a function that's a
little o of f of n in space.
So space little o of f of n is
properly contained within space
f of n.
In other words,
there's something here
which is not in there.
Picture it
pictorially, I'm going
to exhibit some language,
some explicit language
A, which I can do in this much
space, but not in any less.
Now, you can sort of think
of this as a little bit
like the situation for
context-free language
and regular languages, where we
exhibited a particular language
that differentiated-- that
was in context free but not
regular.
And we're going to kind
of do the same thing now.
But the one key difference is
that in the case of separating
the context free
and the regular,
we could give a nice language,
like 0 to the k, 1 to the k.
Here, the language is not going
to be so nice to describe.
It's going to be the language
that some Turing machine we're
going to give decides.
But you're not going
to be able to get
a nice simple understanding of
A. It's going to be whatever
that Turing machine does.
And in that sense, it's
not a very natural language
that's easy to sort of
get your mind around.
So the outline, and really, you
don't have to worry about this,
but maybe it helps.
It's really going to be a kind
of a diagonalization proof.
The way this machine
D is going to operate.
So D is going to give
you my language A.
So D is going to be
designed, and I'm
going to show you D
on the next slide.
D is going to run within my
target space bound, f of n.
And here's the key.
Here's the kicker.
D is going to be designed to
make sure that its language
cannot be done in less space.
And the way it does
that is it makes sure
that its language is different
from any language that
is decidable by a Turing
machine in less space.
And it's going to be different
in at least one place.
So any-- D is going to guarantee
that its language cannot be
done in little o
of f of n space,
because it's going to be
different from every language
that's doable in little o
of f of n space somewhere.
That's the point.
And then the language A is
going to be the language
of this Turing machine D.
So it looks like a tall order.
The D has to make
sure that each--
that for every
machine, its language
differs from that
machine's language,
if that machine is running in
little low o of f of n space.
But it's basically going
to be a diagonalization.
So for all of the different
possible inputs to D,
that input is going
to actually code up
a machine, on which
we're going to make sure
that we're different
from that machine
if it's a small space machine.
Let's see if that--
So I can take a couple
of questions here.
Does f have to be computable?
So that's going to be
one of the conditions
that we're going to
have to guarantee.
Where f satisfies a
technical condition,
yeah, it's going to end
up being have-- it's
going to be computable.
But that's not enough.
Good, good question, though.
OK, so let's move on from there.
So here is-- now what my job is
to give you this Turing machine
D. So D, D's language is
going to be my language A,
which requires f of n space,
cannot be done in less.
OK, oops.
I need to--
I need the full slide here,
so I have to take myself out.
All right.
Now, this is my goal.
I want to exhibit
this language A, which
I can do in this much
space, but not in any less.
And so I'm going to give this
machine D, as I mentioned,
where A is D's language.
D runs in order f of n space.
And that sort of-- that
achieves this part.
And D, make sure that its
language cannot be done in any
less space.
So that achieves this part.
So it's different
from the language
of any machine that runs in
little o of f of n space.
So this is how D
is going to work.
I'm going to try to give
you a little picture
to help see to accompany
the description.
So D gets its input w,
which is of length n.
The very first thing D does
is it marks off f of n space.
Because it's only
allowed to use--
we're only going to allow
D to use f of n space.
Because otherwise, we're
in danger of D not--
of A not being in space f of n.
So D is going to guarantee
that, by making sure
it's going to mark
off f of n space.
And if it ever tries to use
more than that, it just rejects.
But by virtue of that,
we're sure that D's language
is in space f of n.
Because D is an f of n
space Turing machine.
And it's going to be decided.
So this part so far
is not too hard.
Now we're going to start
getting into the meat here.
So if w-- now, what we want
to think of w as a description
of a machine that
we're going to feed--
that's going to run on w.
So this is going
to a little bit,
you know, back to
an earlier when we
talked about diagonalization.
So don't get thrown off by this.
We're going to think of w
not only as the input to D,
but it's also going to be
the description of a machine.
And if it turns out that w
doesn't describe anything,
it's just a junk w, then
we're not interested.
We're just going to
reject on that w.
We're only interested
in the w's that
do describe some machine M.
So if M-- if w describes
some machine M,
then we're going to run M on w.
And we're going to do the
opposite of what M does.
That's the whole idea.
We're just going to make
sure that what we're doing
is not the same as
what M is doing.
So at a high level, the basic
idea for this is not hard.
So we're going to
simulate M on w.
If M rejects, then we'll accept.
If M accepts, then we'll reject.
We're just going
to do the opposite.
And I think that is--
so we have to be careful
when we do the simulation.
This is a little
bit of a detail,
but this is a proof where
you need to pay attention
to some details.
The cost of simulating M on
D is only a constant factor.
Because if M uses a
certain amount of space,
when D is simulating
M, you know,
M may have a larger taper
alphabet than D does,
but D can then encode M's
tape by using several cells
for each of M's cells.
But it's only going to
be a constant factor.
And that's important
here, because we
have to make sure that
if this was a big blowup,
D would not be able to run M.
I think I'm sort of arguing
the details without
making sure we understand
the fundamental concept.
So let me back up.
The point is that D is doing
something the opposite of M.
Now, D can't be
different from every M,
because D itself is a
Turing machine, of course.
But the thing is that
D is only running
with an f of n tape cells.
So it has to be able to
do that simulation of M
within that amount of tape.
If M is using a
lot of tape, then D
is going to use a lot of tape,
and it's just going to reject.
So this is only going to
really come into play,
being able to
simulate M, if M is
using a small amount
of space, so that D
can do this simulation.
Let's just see, maybe--
so there's going to
be some issues here.
But before I get
to that, let's just
see what your questions are.
How can a Turing machine know if
w is encoding some other Turing
machine?
Oh, that's simple.
You know, what is a coding
of a Turing machine?
It's just the standard--
we have a standard coding.
It's just coding the
rules of the machine.
So it has to have states,
transition function,
blah, blah, blah.
So it just has to
be some-- whatever
our encoding for
the Turing machine
is, we can always test whether a
string is a legitimate encoding
of a Turing machine.
So that shouldn't be bad.
Somebody says, why do we
reject if we use more than f
of n cells?
Isn't it OK to use order f of n?
Yes, it could be.
But we have to cut
it off somewhere.
It might be-- it's OK,
we could use 2 f of n.
We could use 10 f of n.
But we have to have
some constant for D.
And that's just
simply constant 1.
So D has to run
within f of n cells.
And that's going to
be good enough for us.
OK, do we have to make sure that
M runs in little o of f of n?
So we can't really
tell whether M is
running in little o of f of n.
All we can tell is whether
we can finish the simulation.
So that's actually going to be--
maybe you can just hold off on
that question, because there
is a point that we have to
follow up on in that, which
is just because
we may or may not
be able to finish
simulating M on this w
doesn't necessarily tell us what
the asymptotic behavior of M
is.
But we'll have to
look at that in a bit.
So somebody saying, what
happens if M loops on w?
That's going to be one of our
issues we have to deal with.
That's a good question there.
Step two alone can use
more than f of n cells.
Yes, step two alone can
use more than f of n cells.
If it does, we're just
going to end up rejecting.
So we're getting
good questions here.
Some of them I'm going
to address anyway,
so why don't we just move on.
So here is sort of a question.
I think this is one of the
questions that related to one
of the ones that got asked.
What happens if it runs in
little o of f of n space?
So remember, what
we're trying to do
is be different from
every small space.
You know, little o of
f of n space machine.
So what if M runs in
little o of f of n space,
but has a big constant?
So what I mean by
that concretely,
is suppose D is
an n cubed space.
So suppose we're trying
to get A in n cubed space,
but show it's not
in n squared space.
So D is going to run in n cubed.
And we have to make sure that
any machine that's running in n
squared space cannot
do the same language.
So we're going to be
different from that.
But the problem is
that the machine
M might be running
in n squared space,
but with a huge constant.
So it might be running
in a million n squared.
So that's still a machine that's
running in little o of n cubed.
And we have to be
different from it.
But for the particular
w we're working on,
we might not have
enough space to run M,
because of the huge constant.
The asymptotic
behavior is only going
to be relevant for large W. For
small w, we may not see that.
We may not have enough
space to run M. So what
are we going to do to fix that?
We're going to run that M on
infinitely many different w's.
There's going to be infinitely
many different w's that are all
going to encode the same M.
And the way I'm
going to do that is
by thinking of w
as representing M,
but having an unbounded number
of trailing zeros after that.
So I'm going to strip off--
the very first thing I'm
going to do with w, is
I'm going to strip off
the trailing zeros up
until the final one.
I'm going to remove those.
And then take the rest, as the
description of the machine.
So now, I'm going
to have potentially
w's that have an enormous
number of zeros at the end,
big enough so that I can see
the asymptotic behavior of M,
and that if M is really running
in little o of f of n space,
I'll have enough space to
run M to completion on w.
And so then I'll be able
to be different from it.
So I'm going to
showing that over here.
So here's a very large
W. I'm going to strip off
the trailing zeros.
The rest of it is
just going to be M.
And I'm going to run
this M on the whole w.
The entire w, without
the zeroes stripped off.
So now M is going to be
running on a very large input,
big enough so that D, which
has asymptotically more space
than M does, will have enough
space to run M to completion.
Now, another question
that got asked.
What happens if M loops?
That's going to be a problem,
because D always has to hold.
And if it just
blindly simulates M,
then D might be
looping on M. Not
if M is going to use a
lot of space, by the way.
Because then D is going
to catch it in step one.
But if M loops on a small
amount of space, then
D might end up looping,
as presently constructed.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to put a counter which
makes it stop if it
runs for 2 to f of n space.
So basically, because
that's how long
D could possibly run
without looping anyway,
and M could be running
without looping anyway.
And so we're going to run
it for this number of steps.
And I'm going to reject
if it hasn't yet halted,
as well as that.
Because it has to be looping
at that point anyway.
And so it's not
interesting for us.
It doesn't matter
what we're going
to do if it hasn't halted.
Because M is not a decider.
And the last thing
is how to compute f.
So I'll try to address
some questions here
in our remaining time.
How to compute f.
So to mark off f of n cells,
we also have to compute f.
I didn't think any of you
guys asked that question,
except maybe sort at
the very beginning,
about f being a
computable function.
Certainly, f is going to
have to be computable.
But not only does it
have to be computable,
it has to be computable
within the space bound.
And that's just going
to be a condition
we're going to impose on f.
It's so called space
constructable, namely,
that you can compute it
within its own space bound.
And all nice functions
that we care about
are going to be
space constructable.
So it doesn't turn out to
be an obstacle to applying
the hierarchy theorem, but it
is a condition that we need.
It actually is not true
without that condition.
Let's just-- oh, I
have a check-in here.
Maybe if we can take a
couple of questions first.
Some of you are anticipating
my check-in actually,
which is good.
So let me hold off on those.
Sorry, a bit confused about what
is M. Can we say D is input M,
and simulates M on-- yeah.
So somebody is saying, can
we say that D has input M,
and simulates M on itself?
Yes, that's exactly
what's happening.
The reason why we're doing that
is because we have to cover all
possible M's.
So as we get all
possible inputs w,
they're going to range
over all possible M's.
And so every possible M
is going to get addressed
to see if we can run it
within the space bound,
and be different from it.
D's job is to be different
from each of those M's.
But it's not-- again,
there is some details here
that got raised in these issues.
But in a sense, this is
just kind of more technical,
I would focus on understanding
what I originally wrote down,
because that's the main idea.
The rest of it is just
implementation details.
So why don't I--
can I give an example of
a nonspace constructable
function?
Yes.
Log log log n space.
You cannot compute log log log
n space within log log log n
space.
And in fact, it's
known that there's
nothing new between constant
space, which is just regular,
and log log log n space.
Anything you can
do in log log log
n space is a regular language.
So the hierarchy theorem
doesn't want to apply there.
Because well, it applies,
but that's not a--
it's not space constructable.
To find higher level large
nonspace constructable
functions, you can do it, but
they're not easy to describe.
Let's do our check-in here.
What happens when
we run D on itself?
I got a couple of people
asking me about that.
So this is just a good
lead in to our check-in.
And this a little--
you really have to
understand what's
going on, to see what does D
do when if you feed in itself,
maybe with some trailing zeros.
Because remember, the algorithm
strips off trailing zeros.
So what does it do in that case?
So here are my options there.
You can get to pick which
one you think is the answer.
So I'll give you
another 30 seconds
on this, because this requires
a little bit of thinking.
If you want to invest in it.
All right.
Wrap this up, guys.
5 seconds to go.
OK, I'm going to end it, so get
your participation points in.
A bunch of you have
not said anything.
Come on.
I can see the count here,
and it's three or four
of you are not answered.
Well, you're going to lose out.
Closing.
All right.
So the right answer is, in
fact, C. It does reject.
Let's just understand
what happened.
It's definitely we don't
get a contradiction.
I mean, this is an
algorithm I just described.
It's going to do something.
I'm assuming the people who
picked E are having fun,
as I did when I came
up with the check-in.
But not a question--
answer A is not
going to be good either,
because D has to be a decider.
So it can't loop on anything.
So the only sort of
reasonable answers
are reject, accept, or reject.
When you run D on itself,
what's it going to try to do?
It's going to-- the
very first thing
it's going to mark
off f of n tape cells.
And then it's going to get
its input, which is itself,
tries to simulate itself
on the same input.
That simulated D is
also going to try
to mark off f of n tape cells.
But due to some
simulation-- there's
going to be some cost
to doing the simulation.
When the simulated
D is going to try
to mark off f of
n tape cells it's
going to blow the
original D's space bound
and exceed the bound.
And so D is going to
reject upright in step one
when it tries to get
an input of itself.
It's very clear what's
going to happen.
It's just going to
reject, because of--
for this, reject in particular.
And notice this, you know, yes.
You know, OK, let me
not try to confuse it.
OK, so that's all I
want to say about this.
Let's now move in our
remaining 7 minutes
to the time hierarchy
theorem, which
is very has the same proof.
But some of the technical
details are slightly different.
So now, if I give
you a time bound,
again, we are going to have
to face with the same notion,
that you have to
be able to compute
f within x amount of time.
So it has to be a
time constructable.
I'm not going to define that.
So there's a language A which
requires that much time.
So it has to be decided
within that much time.
But there's a slight
difference here.
And this is an artifact of
the proof of the theorem,
not because it's an absolute
truth, as far as we know.
It's not that it's not
decidable in little o of f of n.
You actually, you can only
prove something slightly weaker
when you have one
tape Turing machines.
That it's decidable
in little o over--
there's a slight gap
in what you can prove.
So it's not only that
you can't prove--
it requires little o.
But little o of--
little o of f of
n over log f of n
is what you can prove that you
get from this time hierarchy
theorem.
But let's not get caught
up on that for now.
So the proof outline is the
same outline as we had before.
We're going to give a D that
runs in order f of n time.
So it ensures that the language
is in that time complexity
class time f of n.
And it makes sure it's different
from every machine that
runs faster.
By some significant--
by a log factor faster.
And so, why don't I
show how that goes.
The proof is, in some ways,
almost exactly the same.
I'm going to give a D, which
runs in this much time,
and it shows it's
different from every M that
runs in a lot less time.
Here is the algorithm for
D. Now, it computes f of n.
But it does something a
little different with f of n.
Remember, in the space
hierarchy theorem,
we marked off f of n space.
Now, this f of n is going to be
used for a different purpose.
It's going to be a clock.
And you have to shut M down
if it runs for more than f
of n steps.
Not if it uses more
than f of n space.
Because we're only interested in
M's that use significantly less
than f of n time.
So we're going to run M for
f for some number of steps.
Whatever M says, we're
going to do the opposite.
And only if we can actually
finish that simulation,
will we be able to
be sure that we're
different from what M is doing.
So this is the whole
algorithm here.
We don't have to do any
further modifications.
And where is that log
n factor coming from?
It's actually coming
from a funny place.
And you have to get into a
little bit of the guts of this.
When you're simulating M on
w, remember that M itself
was described by w.
So you're going to
have to write down
a copy of M, which is just
as described by W. And then
so you're going
to-- and then you're
going to have the tape
that M is working on,
which is starting
out with w on it.
And you have to be, now you
have to be a little careful
how you manage that.
Because if your
description of M is just
sitting at the beginning of the
tape, as you're simulating M,
every time you do one step
in modifying the tape,
you don't want to
have to go back
to the beginning of the tape
to look up the next step of M.
So you actually have to
carry M along with you
as you're doing the simulation.
And you can do that by expanding
the tape alphabet of the tape
so that you can effectively
have two symbols on one cell.
One is going to be
for describing M,
and the other one is going to
be for just for the simulation
tape.
And you'll be carrying
M along with you
wherever your head
is, so you don't have
to go very far to look up M.
And so that's all possible,
because that's going to add only
a constant factor, because M
is fixed in size,
doesn't depend on--
for large inputs
to M, M is fixed.
But the tricky thing
here is the counter,
to make sure we're not
using too much time.
The counter has size log
f of n, because that's
how big it has to count up to
so you can shut it down if it's
going to exceed f of n steps.
And let's see,
you'll have to run
for a certain amount of time.
And keeping the
counter nearby has--
the counter now, it
can be pretty big.
And so that's going to cost you
a log factor of simulation cost
to move that counter
around all the time.
And so that's why you have to
run for only a log factor less,
so that you can actually
finish within f of n time,
as you're required to do.
I realize that that's
a mouthful there.
And you may not have
all understood that.
It doesn't matter.
It's not that critical.
I think what I'm really
more concerned is
you understand the main idea
of the hierarchy theorem.
Some of these implementation
details, if you don't get them,
I wouldn't worry about it.
I feel I have to include
them for completeness sake
and to be honest with
you about the proof.
But if you didn't follow
everything, that's OK.
I do want to understand the main
idea, though, of the algorithm,
making sure that what it's
doing is different from what
every machine is doing if that
machine runs in little o of f
of n space or a small amount
of time, little o of f of n
over log f of n time.
And I think we're
going to end here.
So we're pretty
much out of time.
I'm going to stick
around for a little bit,
in case there's
any questions here.
Oh, there's one last
check-in though.
Let's look at this.
This is kind of an
interesting sort of follow on
to the hierarchy theorem.
If you look at the two
questions, does L equal P,
and does P equal P space?
These are both
unsolved problems.
What, if anything, does
the hierarchy theorem
tell us about those questions?
And it's kind of interesting,
that there are actually-- well,
I'll leave it to you to tell
me if you can see what it
might actually be telling you.
Closing.
Get your answer in.
OK, 1, 2, 3.
I feel like I'm running
an auction house here.
And I should have a gavel.
Yes, in fact, we know
that these are separated.
So it's not-- even
though we don't
know if L equals P,
or P equal P space,
they can't both be equal.
Because then L
would equal P space,
and we know that's false.
So at least one of
these has the answer no.
So with that, let's
wrap up today's lecture.
Now we prove these
hierarchy theorems.
And why don't we just--
I'm going to shut us down here.
But before-- well,
I mean, we're over,
so you can feel free to go.
But I'll stick around in case
anybody has any questions
for a few minutes anyway.
And then we'll call it a day.
Since we just showed space N
is a proper subset of space N
to the K for any K,
why can't we also say
space N is a proper
subset of P space?
Yes, space N is a proper
subset of P space.
Yeah.
So somebody just
asked, we just showed
that space N is a proper subset
of space N to the K. Does
that also say that space N is
a proper subset of P space?
Definitely.
Space N to the K is a proper
subset of space N to the K
plus 1, which is a
subset of P space.
So any fixed polynomial is
going to be a subset of P space,
because P space includes
all the polynomials.
Which of the two
unsolved problems--
whoops-- do I think is more
like likely to be true?
Well, I think most--
I mean, I would bet that
both of these are not equal.
So both of these have answer no.
It would be weird, you know,
I mean, you think L equals P?
That anything can do
in polynomial time
you can do in log space?
Log space is incredibly weak.
And P space is
incredibly strong.
I would be shocked if
either of these were equal.
So we just-- the
problem is that we
don't have a method for
proving problems are actually,
have high complexity
of any sort.
We don't know how to
show things outside of L.
Don't know how to show
things outside of P. Except
by using the hierarchy theorem.
Diagonalization
is the only method
that we have for showing
things are outside of classes.
And there's reason
to believe, as well.
This we'll get to, I think,
next lecture, in fact.
There's kind of reasons to
believe that the hierarchy
theorem type argument,
which is diagonalization
is not going to answer
those kinds of questions.
So we need a different method.
And diagonalization
is all we got.
Good question, though.
If I didn't get to
answer your question,
you have a question
for me, ask it again,
because it's got buried.
So it means we are very far
from disproving P versus NP,
is that right?
It could happen tomorrow.
How can you tell?
It doesn't-- it seems clear
that the present state
of mathematics, as of right
now, is we don't have a clue how
to answer those
kinds of questions.
And it's not obvious that
we've even made any progress.
But you know, that's
the nature of the game.
That's the nature of the beast.
Somebody gets a good idea, and
all of a sudden lots of things
can change.
And that can happen
at any point.
Maybe one of you guys.
When would these results first--
the stuff.
OK.
The hierarchy theorem is old.
That goes back to the very--
when time classes were first
defined, I think it's
one of the first results
to show the hierarchy.
And that's late '60s.
The NL equal coNL, I think I
mentioned, was like mid-1980s.
Much later.
I mean, from your
points of view,
it was back in the
cave age either way.
But yeah, but the
hierarchy theorem,
that actually predates
my coming into the field.
But the NL equal coNL,
that was something
that I personally experienced
how surprised people were.
I think I'm going to send
you off, all off on your way.
But good having you here.
And have a good
weekend, everybody.
And I will see you on Tuesday.
Bye-bye.